when we were trying these cases we were
trying one after the other so I ended up
spending like the better part of a year
in San Francisco and every morning when
I was in San Francisco before court I
would go down to the courthouse to the
uh to the gym
in Union Square
Union Square is the center of San
Francisco and it's the center of
Commerce it has all the big uh um you
know American iconic American stores
like uh Macy's and Bloomingdale's and uh
Nordstrom and GAP and Old Navy and Levi
and then it has all the foreign stores
like Prada and de la Valley and Gucci
and Ferragamo Hermes yeah Ferragamo and
uh Burberry and all of those so it's
like Fifth Avenue it is the Fifth Avenue
and people come from Asia all over to do
their shopping there
so you know I went back three weeks ago
and it was astonishing those houses are
or those stores are all boarded up
they're every one of them is closed wow
and
they're closed because all of them
homeless on the street making the chaos
that's going on in the street in San
Francisco makes people feel unsafe
here's what you know my son
actually because I I had a lot of
I have a lot of assumptions about why
people are homeless
and it it's you know there's 525 000
homeless people in this country
and but
50 of the unsheltered homeless are in
California
okay but California only has 12 of the
population but it's 50 of the of the
unsheltered homeless and unsheltered
almost means homeless I don't have a
place to sleep yeah it's okay it's
people who are you know on the sidewalk
like freelance yeah right or they're in
shelter you know they're yeah like free
range yeah
so
um my assign here's my assumptions that
homelessness is linked to drug addiction
it's linked to mental illness
um it's linked to you know poverty
and that people are in one of the
reasons there's so many homeless in
California is that everybody knows that
San Francisco
as this very generous kind of giving
attitude towards social services and so
if you're homeless anywhere else in the
country you you know you you'd like to
move the good weather yeah you know you
don't want to be in New York sleeping on
a great in the middle of winter when
it's snowing
get on a Greyhound and come out to San
Francisco and you know and
celebrate yeah and I also had heard this
which turns out not to be true that that
in some cities like Dallas
or Nashville if you are homeless at a uh
instead of putting you in jail
they give you a bus ticket to San
Francisco oh wow so I don't know if it's
true or not but anyway so my son
turn me on to this writer called my son
Connor and who you know
Matthew Desmond and Matthew Desmond has
written these books on homelessness and
he's done these studies on homelessness
and they in in San Francisco they
actually went around and interviewed
thousands and thousands of homeless
people
and what they found is
that
um
that the people who are homeless in San
Francisco are from San Francisco and
they're from California and they weren't
they didn't come from somewhere so it's
not a lot of people yeah Boston or
transplants or whatever right
he also says that
it it has it it has very little to do
with drug addiction you know the states
like West Virginia
as much more drug addiction in San
Francisco and yet it doesn't have a
homeless problems West Virginia has much
worse poverty problem than San Francisco
San Francisco actually I think it's the
richest city in the country and maybe
wrong but I think it's the riches and
um and it doesn't so and in terms of
mental illness you have to assume
they're the same yeah you know there's a
reason but but also Detroit Detroit has
a much higher drug addiction much higher
poverty and it doesn't have a homeless
problem
and what Matthew Desmond says is the
reason for almost one reason one reason
is housing prices it all has to do with
with housing prices in California you
know we have the highest housing prices
in the country
um here in La Where We Are
the average home cost 815
000 which means you have to earn 250 000
to be able to pay to be able to pay for
that and why do they get so high like is
it demand that makes them so high I'm
going to tell you this the average home
in our country
two years ago was 215 000 mm-hmm he
today is 400 000. and the interest rates
have gone from three to seven percent so
kids today like your kids and my kids
are never gonna buy a home
you know it used to be but if so if
they're not going to buy a home yeah and
the median price of home sold by
Realtors is risen sharply since the
beginning of their family yeah and and
here's why this is happening
there's three big companies uh BlackRock
State Street yeah these the biggest
companies you know and they have a
monopoly on a lot of the housing market
right well what they do they own
everything okay including they on each
other so it's really just one big
company and and BlackRock that it has 10
trillion dollars under management
the GDP of California is three or ten
trillion the GDP of California is three
trillion dollars
and so they're three times the size of
California California economy is the
fifth largest in the world of all
Nations so when you have that much
control can't you just make your own
universe
so they own
those three companies own 88 of the s p
500. so they basically just own
everything and now what they've decided
is they want to own every single family
home in our country so they're that and
and they're now on track there's now on
trajectory if we continue it on this
trajectory they will own these
corporations
will own 60 of the uh single family
homes in our country and they're you
know they they pay nothing for money so
they're like if you're the richest
person in the country
their blackrock's cost of money is 30
lower than you so you you know when so
they're competing against our kids and
your kids why is it so different
they want it now they want to own
everything so why is the percentage of
the cost of the value of of borrowing oh
because they are that their credit is so
impeccable oh I see they have like 900.
yeah so they they got the better than
the best credit rating I think I got 670
or something I don't know what's okay I
don't know yeah but isn't that like
privatized communism or something that's
what it feels like well yeah it's like
socialism for the rich and you know this
is barbaric merciless
ruthless Savage yeah do you think
there's some trickle-down effect of that
that makes people feel like
yeah I don't know I mean I I was talking
we had this guy John viveki on and he
talks a lot about meaning and stuff like
that you know and he said that people
feeling like they're part of a country
or they're they have like a part of a
home you know part of a group it it
creates a lot of meaning for them you
know just in their life yeah and I think
I noticed even with my own like probably
like our parents and stuff I think a lot
of them were very like pro-america and
like you know they had family members
that died for our country and they you
know it meant something to them to be
part of America and then now I think a
lot of them see this kind of unfolding
or like kind of the flag kind of like
fraying at the stitching you know and I
think it's very scary because if you
wanna if you start to feel like you
don't have your country
then I think then you start to feel like
okay it's every man for himself in a way
does that make any sense yeah and you
know
and you're absolutely right there's a
poll that came out three weeks ago that
showed that in 2013
kids between 18 and 35 years old that 85
percent of Young Americans
um said they were proud of the United
States and then another poll that Saint
Paul came out three weeks ago that
showed that only 17 of kids say that
they're proud to be and I said really
you know devastating but one of the
things that you were saying I think is
true that
if you own a home
you care more about your community you
care about the schools you know you care
about the police oh that's a great point
the hospital you take care of your
garden you know you make it look nice
you might be more likely to help your
neighbor exactly because you're there
you're part of the community
and turning us all into you know and you
it you also are a participant in the
capitalist system because
if you own a home you have Equity yeah
which means let's say you want to start
a business even like a tiny business
like you know buying a sewing machine
yeah doing sewing what else can we do
you can do or you know if you want to
start at restaurants popcorn like a
caramel corn exactly something like that
yeah and
um but you could get a loan on you can
go alone right on your house and so you
you have an entree and a capitalist
system yeah and you make you because
then you're always pop everything's
possible you could sit down with your
family at night and be like hey Mom and
Dad are thinking about doing this
business what do you guys think and
maybe your son's proud of you and it
creates excitement in your house you
know and even if like I remember my mom
went to law school and she couldn't do
it because she had too many kids and it
was too much work but I was still always
proud of her that she tried to do it you
know like I think yeah having the the
financial ability to do stuff like that
is just so important man and then
otherwise you feel yeah if you're just a
renter if everybody's a renter you don't
nobody you just feel like you're like a
renter by force like you don't even have
a choice to be a renter you know yeah
um yeah that's kind of scary how do we
battle against that and is it something
that a president can do or a political
official can do or it's something that
how do you how do we turn reverse that
um well I don't know I mean there
there's parts of their
um of of what they're doing that yeah a
president can do for example they own
all the packing companies so there's
only four meat backing companies and and
those companies have a Stranglehold on
farmers and consumers and they should
have been prosecuted a long time ago for
antitrust but because BlackRock is so
powerful nobody will touch them wow and
so that's a dark arts huh yeah I mean
they're just you know what they're doing
is they're just they're just strip
mining the wealth and Equity from the
American middle class
and you see that you know um yeah it's
sad and how do we how do who is it who
is Blackrock
the head of it is uh as the CEO is I
call Larry Fink
he's also on the board of directors of
the world economic Forum so in the world
economic Forum you know is meets him to
have it's a billionaires boys club uh
meeting to have us every year and they
try to figure out what
um their plans are for the rest of
humanity are they greedy I would say
they're they're they they have a bad
reputation for a very self-serving
policies their big policy is called the
Great reset
and what here's Cloud Schwab says
famously he says under the great reset
you will have not you will own nothing
but you will be happy
so that's why that's what they believe
yeah so they do have a belief their
belief is that you will own nothing but
you'll be happy all of us will own
nothing but they will work because they
will own everything
and they may be a little happier who
knows wow